[Música]
el próximo 30 de abril es una fecha de
suma importancia Paraguay elegirá a su
nuevo presidente en medio de un clima
político en el que están en juego
múltiples factores no sobra decir que
desde ya estos comicios se muestran como
una elección reñida que puede marcar un
giro o no en la política paraguaya
Quiénes son Entonces los protagonistas
principales de esta historia tenemos a
Santiago Peña de la asociación nacional
republicana conocido como el partido
Colorado que es un partido tradicional
en la política paraguaya Efraín alegre
del partido liberal radical auténtico
llega apalancado por un grupo de
partidos de oposición congregados en la
llamada concertación nacional también
disputa la Silla presidencial paraguayo
cubas por el CN que es el partido
Cruzada Nacional euclides Acevedo del
movimiento nueva República también
participan estos comicios y cierro Con
un tal vez un muy conocido para algunos
de ustedes José Luis chilavert del PJ al
partido de la Juventud transportado por
haber sido el guardameta de la selección
paraguaya de fútbol y tal vez uno de los
más destacados deportistas en América
Latina en las últimas décadas así las
cosas 5 millones de ciudadanos
paraguayos están llamados a las urnas en
las que tal vez
la democracia O tal vez es uno de los
países que es considerado como una de
las democracias más jóvenes de América
del Sur porque vale la pena recordar que
recién en 1989 este país puso fin a una
larga dictadura militar Pero entonces
qué es lo que está en juego y cuáles son
los retos de este país pues justamente
mantener o reforzar las bases de esa
democracia debido a una alta apatía por
parte de los votantes hacia estas
elecciones presidenciales pocos
ciudadanos se identifican con las
propuestas de los candidatos la
intervención de Estados Unidos en estos
comicios debido a diferentes sanciones y
requerimientos judiciales del
expresidente Horacio cartes es que es
considerado los exponentes del partido
Colorado sin duda alguna también han
modificado el ambiente electoral en
Paraguay y esto se ve reflejado también
en esa fragmentación que hay por parte
del oficialismo de Cara a estos comicios
Quien llegue a la Silla presidencial
recibirá un país con una alta deuda
pública pobreza corrupción condiciones
de desigualdad muy grandes inseguridad y
el impacto de grupos ligados al
narcotráfico si miramos todos estos
factores no solamente algo que sucede en
Paraguay es prácticamente ya el mismo
escenario en todos los países de América
Latina pobreza deuda narcotráfico e
inseguridad prácticamente son los mismos
factores a lo largo y ancho de nuestro
continente pero lo cierto es que el
narcotráfico muy pocos sectores de la
política paraguaya han intentado
combatirlo también hay que decir que es
una economía que digamos puede estar
creciendo a un buen ritmo pese a estar
levantándose de lo que dejó la pandemia
del Coby 19 por eso hoy en el debate de
France 24 le damos una mirada en general
al clima electoral en Paraguay de Cara a
esas elecciones presidenciales y para
analizar el tema hemos invitado a Katia
gorastiaga ella es docente e
investigadora sobre democracia e
instituciones políticas también es
doctora en investigación en ciencias
sociales en mención en ciencia política
y maestra en ciencias sociales por la
facultad latinoamericana de ciencias
sociales flaxo México y también está con
nosotros Camilo filártiga él es abogado
máster en estudios políticos y docente e
investigador de la Universidad Católica
de Asunción la capital paraguaya les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales nos encuentran en
Twitter en Facebook en instagram allí
nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_s o raya al piso la etiqueta
para que dejen los comentarios numeral
el debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo no olviden
también que todos los contenidos del
programa están también disponibles en
como ustedes ven en pantalla en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
le doy entonces la bienvenida a Katia en
la ciudad de Asunción Katia Gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en el debate en
France 24 bienvenida y Punto de partida
para la discusión un panorama general
del ambiente electoral en Paraguay de
Cara a estos comicios para conocer
posiciones y perspectivas bienvenida
Hola Santiago Antes que nada Muchas
gracias a el debate por la invitación
y respondiendo de entrada a tu pregunta
el clima electoral y está bastante
entre tranquilo y agitado podríamos
decir tranquilo en el sentido que no
están pasando grandes cosas todavía
porque quedan tres semanas
pero más que agitado sería con mucha
incertidumbre porque como se acostumbra
en esta época del año hay varias
encuestas que están saliendo algunas un
poco más serias que otras pero sobre
todo con datos muy dispares entonces
genera genera como un poco incertidumbre
leer
o de datos nos genera un poco de
incertidumbre En cual confiar y en cuál
no lo que hace también que genere
incertidumbre el resultado que se espera
para el 30 de abril
la opinión de Katy en la ciudad de
Asunción y ahora le doy la palabra a
nuestro otro invitado Camilo también
allí en la capital paraguaya Bienvenido
al programa Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos hoy y Camilo su panorama
general de lo que se está viviendo allí
en este país suramericano bienvenido
Hola Santiago un placer Muchas gracias
por la invitación un saludo también a la
querida amiga Katia sí efectivamente
coincido con el con el análisis de Katia
es una campaña te diría atípica quizás
hay elementos
nuevos en en la campaña electoral que no
se han dado en campañas anteriores
pienso principalmente en la sanción del
gobierno americano sobre altos
exponentes del partido Colorado que
quieras o no genera un impacto en la
campaña electoral un impacto en el
financiamiento de la campaña del partido
socialista
y se genera como te digo este este
ambiente atípico de aparente baja
intensidad en cuanto a movilización a
actos de campaña verdad y con la
incertidumbre Respecto a los resultados
aquí si bien hay una
proliferación de encuestas
hay ya un manto de duda sobre la mayoría
de ellas
y lo que lo que lo que creo yo y Y hay
como un consenso generalizado es que el
resultado va a ser un resultado muy
estrecho entre ambas entre las
principales candidaturas en este caso
Santiago peña del partido Colorado y
Efraín alegre que representa la
concertación Sí bueno viendo este
panorama general de lo que está
sucediendo allí en Paraguay Comencemos
entonces hablando justamente por esas en
por motivos editoriales yo no puedo dar
números ni ni destacar a uno u otro de
los candidatos pero lo que uno ve con
estas encuestas sobre todo algunas de
empresas extranjeras en particular
algunas brasileñas dan prácticamente un
empate técnico o como decía Camilo un
una diferencia en los porcentajes mínimo
aquí lo que uno ve es que tal vez
Paraguay está viviendo el mismo
escenario que han vivido otros países de
América Latina como lo vivió Brasil como
lo vivió Colombia como lo ha vivido
otras naciones solo bueno Perú que ya
sabemos el escenario político en el que
está esto
esto que deja sobre la mesa Camilo para
hacer la ronda la inversa en cuanto al
votante paraguayo que hay una división
en la sociedad paraguaya entre quienes
quieren darle tal vez esa continuidad al
longevo partido Colorado o que tal vez
buscan una nueva perspectiva política
Paraguay en otra fuerza política
bueno esa es una de las grandes
incertidumbres ya en el año 2018 en las
últimas elecciones la diferencia entre
Mario abdo Benítez presidenta actual que
ganó esas elecciones y Efraín alegre ya
había sido muy estrecha en ese momento
la gran incógnita en este momento es
saber si tendremos continuidad de esta
casi hegemonía colorada en en estos más
de 30 años de democratización en
Paraguay o se da un voto de confianza a
el a la alternancia en el en el proceso
político recuerda importante recordar
que hemos tenido entre el 2018 y el 2012
un breve paréntesis de gobierno de
oposición encabezado por el el obispo
progresista Fernando Lugo pero desde
1947 en tenemos prácticamente una
hegemonía del partido Colorado en el
poder en el en la en la presidencia El
Ejecutivo lo cual también habla de un de
una característica bastante particular
del proceso político paraguayo lo eran
la gran incógnita es saber si el
electorado la ciudadanía va a apostar
por una alternancia o va a primar la
maquinaria colorada que recordemos
importante acotar aquí la altísima
membresía afiliación de los de los dos
principales partidos políticos el
partido liberal y el partido Colorado
tienen afiliaciones que rondan el millón
y medio de afiliado en caso del partido
liberal y más de dos millones de
afiliados en caso del partido Colorado
la palabra a usted que qué piensa cómo
ve el panorama dentro del electorado muy
fragmentado en cuanto a darle un nuevo
aire político a Paraguay continuar un
poco el continuismo político o
simplemente una apatía por exactamente
ver a los mismos dos partidos de siempre
encabezando encuestas y disputándose la
presidencia
lo que pasa es que no son no son los dos
partidos de siempre hay uno que es el
partido de siempre que es el partido
Colorado pero la oposición con sus luces
y sus sombras logró
unirse en una gran fuerza de
para disputar el el poder al partido
Colorado Pero hay dos cuestiones ahí que
que comentó Camilo que son importantes
por un lado
el tema de la continuidad que viene de
Bueno una época de la tercera ola de la
Democracia hablamos de treinta y cinco
años con un breve periodo del 2008 al
2012 una suerte de primavera democrática
eh
a la fecha pero en este escenario actual
se dieron dos ay creo que hay dos
eventos que son muy importantes por un
lado eso que dije de la fuerza de la
concertación o de la oposición que logró
aliarse alrededor de dos candidatos Pero
además
las sanciones que vinieron de la
Embajada Americana al presidente del
partido Colorado han significado que la
maquinaria colorada que si viene fuerte
y va a seguir siendo fuerte esté un poco
debilitada debido a que los recursos
económicos con los que cuentan
tradicionalmente quizás no sean los
mismos que ahora de hecho en esta semana
estuvimos leyendo que el partido
Colorado que habitualmente pide
préstamos bancarios y demás para poder
solventar lo que es la la etapa final de
la campaña política no está consiguiendo
esos préstamos porque el ordenador de
gastos es Horacio cartes y Horacio
cartes ahora mismo Está
Vedado de pedir préstamos a bancos que
trabajen con Estados Unidos Entonces eso
genera de dificultades ahora lo que
respecta al votante el voto duro va a
seguir siendo voto duro ya sea liberal o
Colorado pero hay como una nueva
conciencia justamente también
influenciada por lo que hizo por estas
declaraciones de la Embajada Americana y
por otros hechos que se que se que han
tomado conocimiento en los últimos
tiempos que quizá gente que
tradicionalmente votaba por el partido
Colorado por una cuestión de no sé vamos
a llamarle confianza
ahora Lo está pensando mejor digamos que
tal vez está pensando que la alternancia
sería una buena opción para ver cómo
gobiernan los otros yo en lo personal
creo que la alternancia siempre es
saludable para para la democracia y en
eso nos diferenciamos a los otros países
a los otros países con los que nos
comparaste nosotros tuvimos un brevísimo
periodo de cuatro años de alternancia
los otros países sonaste como brasileños
y demás digamos que están más
acostumbrados a alternar entre partidos
políticos acá no Y eso también
por un lado que creemos que genera
esperanza por otro lado genera miedo
también porque no sabes que con qué se
vienen estos nuevos si es que se vienen
claro y porque justamente en ese momento
de la alternancia Katia pues ese ese
gobierno de Lugo no llegó a fin no llegó
a su puerto de finalización fue
destituido por el congreso algunos dicen
que fue un golpe de estado leve otros
sectores lo ven como que era El proceder
correcto y eso a nivel internacional a
Paraguay le costó muchísimas sanciones y
críticas incluso eso Deja ustedes me
corregirán todavía deja algunas heridas
por ahí y por eso también puede ser
parte del origen de esa incertidumbre
entre darle esa alternancia al poder o
no precisamente por ese capítulo Me
detengo a hablar del partido Colorado no
porque queramos acá destacar la fuerza
política que significa sino que ha sido
un partido que ha gobernado Paraguay
durante décadas y en este momento está
en una coyuntura muy particular ya Katy
y Camilo lo mencionaban por estas
sanciones que ha impuesto Estados Unidos
a uno de sus que es el expresidente
cartes Y eso ha cambiado un poco el
panorama de ese partido de Cara a estos
comicios Katia para hacer la ronda la
inversa qué tan fragmentado está el
partido Colorado en este momento de cara
estos comicios entendiendo también que
el cartismo no es afín o no es lo mismo
que hablar de partido Colorado o
coloradismo si se le puede llamar así
hay ciertas divisiones y esto que tanto
está afectando para los comicios Qué
tanto está impactando dentro de la
ciudadanía
llegado pero no creo yo que no con el
nivel de fragmentación que llegó en el
2008 que fue lo que permitió la victoria
de Lugo igual hay una práctica
tradicional acá en Paraguay que de Cara
a los comicios previo a los comicios se
odian se maltratan se insultan pero de
Cara a los comicios se da lo que se
llama el gran abrazo republicano entre
los diferentes movimientos del partido
Colorado sin embargo ese gran abrazo
republicano que es casi una ficción
en estos momentos se ve digamos que
debilitado porque por ejemplo en los
actos que lidera Santiago Peña que es el
candidato el candidato a la presidencia
por el partido Colorado se ve muy poca
presencia de los de gente o de
referentes de los movimientos internos
del partido Colorado eso da la eso da la
la señal de que las cosas no están
también al interior del partido Colorado
Y si vos seguís si vos como votantes
seguiste a un líder a un referente en
particular y no le ves en ninguno de los
actos partidarios Yo creo que es gente
genera la duda también sí
tu voto tiene que estar hacia ahí sí o
no Yo creo que va a generar un poco de
abstención también esta situación
entonces la fragmentación sí existe sí
sino
no te das cuenta pero si la fi no te das
cuenta y eso quiere decir que si ha
habido un impacto por parte de esas
sanciones de Estados Unidos también en
cierta forma hacia estos líderes del
partido Camilo su opinión
sí la fragmentación existe por más de
que se quiera negar y que detrás de la
figura del abrazo republicano se quiera
esconder la fragmentación existe o sea
Ahí hay una grieta una brecha digamos
que no está cerrada internamente el
propio presidente de la república cada
vez que se puede manifestar se
manifiesta de manera muy crítica hacia
hacia Horacio cartes hacia este hacia lo
que es el cartismo digamos verdad
la gran incógnita es saber cómo cómo va
a impactar eso el Día de las elecciones
Y eso efectivamente va a derivar en un
en brazos Caídos de un sector importante
de la militancia que es la que se
moviliza el el día el Día de las
elecciones si si es que eso va a
impactado no en lo que es el
funcionamiento de la maquinaria colorada
el Día de las elecciones
que ahí hay que agregar otro elemento
además de esta brecha interna no cerrada
que es el aspecto del financiamiento
ya lo decía Katia los problemas para el
partido Colorado para para obtener
préstamos para financiar la campaña eso
se mantiene hasta ahora Aparentemente
están en vías de de conseguir un
préstamo de una entidad bancaria local
pero que no que no es todo lo que ellos
estaban solicitando y y ese detalle no
es menor Santiago Porque nuestro proceso
electoral tiene una característica
también particular el Día de las
elecciones los partidos políticos
tienen una serie de gastos muy
importantes para movilizar y para poder
hacer posible el Día de las elecciones
verdad Y eso tiene que ver con traslado
de electores tiene que ver con miembros
de mesa que puedan estar de manera
efectiva cuidando los votos o
controlando los votos tiene que ver con
todo el el el el el el aparato que los
partidos necesitan para el Día de las
elecciones ahí hay una erosión muy
importante que los partidos tienen que
hacer y para lo cual el financiamiento
es fundamental ver la logística de los
partidos el Día de las elecciones y de
La otra cara de la moneda de del lado
del partido liberal que está encabezado
por Efraín alegre y una concertación
nacional varios partidos políticos de la
oposición han logrado conformar esta
esta coalición alegre
que es el candidato Efraín alegre se
presenta por tercera vez a estas
elecciones presidenciales qué tan
cohesionada está la oposición qué tan
fuerte está pesando y pisando en este
sector electoral Camilo para estas
elecciones sí Bueno ahí Yo quiero
distinguir dos cosas en primer lugar la
figura de Efraín Alegre en lo personal
creo que es una figura fuerte un
liderazgo fuerte dentro de la oposición
es la figura que ha eh que que se ha
opuesto digamos al modelo del cartismo
de manera más protagónica Si se quiere
desde el 2013 Aproximadamente en
adelante es la referencia
opositora a lo que representa el
cartismo verdad y ha logrado además un
hecho no menor que es cohesionar a toda
la oposición o a casi toda la oposición
en torno a lo que es la concertación que
la concertación como figura jurídica es
también una Innovación de este proceso
electoral y te diría yo es una es un
desafío para incluso para el sistema de
partido paraguayo verdad la concertación
implica para los partidos que lo que la
componen una serie de responsabilidades
y obligaciones
mayor que las alianzas electorales que
eran las figuras tradicionales bajo las
cuales los partidos de oposición
competían contra el partido Colorado
hablemos ahora habiendo ya hecho un poco
el barrio de lo que están de lo que
están viviendo allí en Paraguay Quiénes
son las caras fuertes de Cara a estos
comicios presidenciales me gustaría
preguntarle a Katia Camilo Qué es lo que
está en juego allí en Paraguay y qué es
lo que piden los paraguayos qué es lo
que hablan los paraguayos en la calle en
su día a día de lo que necesita el país
como lo decía yo tiene unos factores que
son comunes para la mayoría de los
países de América Latina pobreza mejorar
la educación combatir el narcotráfico
que ya se volvió prácticamente Pues un
mal regional ya no es particular de
Colombia y México y algunos estados
Centroamericanos ya es prácticamente
tiene presencia en toda la región qué es
lo que están pidiendo los paraguayos en
las calles Qué es lo que esperan ellos
de este nuevo presidente que pueda
llegar a la Silla presidencial las
Llanas Asunción Katia
en general lo que se escucha se escuchan
las calles es principalmente
una lucha frontal contra la corrupción
en las que está sumamente enquistada en
las instituciones públicas de eso se
habla mucho también se habla mucho del
tema del desempleo
desde los movimientos feministas también
se habla mucho de la participación
protagónica de las mujeres en la en el
gabinete presidencial
se habla mucho de la de la debilidad o
de la pobreza que hay en la educación y
ni qué decir en el sistema de salud que
con la pandemia lo que nos habían dado
cuenta se dieron cuenta que nuestro
sistema de salud está completamente
desfasado y es completamente
insuficiente para satisfacer las
necesidades de la ciudadanía Entonces yo
creo que esos son los puntos que más se
hablan pero sobre todo en estos últimos
días
se está hablando mucho del tema de la
corrupción desterrar la corrupción se
están moviendo juicios políticos
contra contra diversos políticos que
fueron sancionados por la Embajada
Americana pero también otros políticos
que ya se Habían intentado hacerle
juicios juicios pero no sabían podido no
solamente los a ver digamos la Embajada
Americana tiene mucho que ver en lo que
está en alguna de las cosas que están
pasando pero no es tampoco determinante
en cierto otro en otros procesos que se
están iniciando se están queriendo
iniciar por ejemplo recientemente hubo
un cambio del fiscal general de la
república Y lo primero que se hizo fue
presentar un expediente o se está
tratando de presentar un expediente
penal en contra de la de la fiscal acá
de la fiscal general que acaba de salir
hoy se presentó el nivel acusatorio
contra uno de los miembros del Jurado
enjuiciamiento de magistrado de Camilo
corregimiento Y es que estoy equivocado
en la institución
entre otros procesos de ese tipo
entonces la gente sobre todo se le ve
cansada de la corrupción es como el tema
número uno hoy en día y para mí el tema
número dos el tema de salud que con la
pandemia que fuimos todos
que creo que también es transversal para
toda la región los sistemas de salud de
América Latina quedaron en evidencia a
raíz de la pandemia de Kobe 19 Camilo su
opinión lo que quieren los paraguayos en
estas elecciones Sí bueno para para no
no repetirlo lo que planteó Katia que
con lo cual yo yo también estoy de
acuerdo
tenemos en este momento un millón 950
mil personas Aproximadamente en pobreza
26%
Esa esa reducción de la pobreza que
había sido muy importante
entre el 2003 y este el 2012
aproximadamente
2010 2003 al 2010 más o menos fue por
una reducción muy importante Ya desde
hace unos años se ha desacelerado se ha
estancado entonces hay una situación y
bueno por supuesto agudizado por la
situación de la pandemia verdad el
acceso a mejores condiciones de vida
el aspecto educativo Verdad que es una
privación de un derecho fundamental para
cientos y miles de niños en el Paraguay
son aspectos lacerantes y son deudas
sociales de nuestra democracia la
democracia paraguaya en estos treinta
años o un poco más de 30 años ha tenido
un avance muy importante en lo que es el
diseño de las reglas de juego de las
instituciones sin embargo hay un retraso
y una deuda muy importante en materia en
materia social garantizar y consolidar
el estado social de derecho que tiene
Rango constitucional sigue siendo una
deuda pendiente en nuestro país y por
supuesto hoy en día
el aspecto de la de La amenaza que
genera el crimen organizado a una
institucionalidad que de por sí ya es
débil una una institucionalidad que hace
aguas y que necesita
fortalecerse y en ese sentido
estos últimos cambios importantes de
este los principales referentes en los
órganos constitucionales claves del
Ministerio Público este la Corte Suprema
el tribunal superior de justicia
electoral creo que genera una nueva
expectativa también en la ciudadanía de
que puedan hacerse mejor las cosas
verdad Camilo te toca un punto
importante que le iba a preguntar y es
la institucionalidad paraguaya hemos
hablado de esas encuestas electorales
que pocos creen en los resultados
confían un poco más en las encuestas que
desde el exterior o empresas que son
extranjeras pero que están haciendo la
labor de campo allí en Paraguay de
carastos a estos comicios y se habla de
la institucionalidad de esta joven
democracia usted lo estaba mencionando
también Que tanto se puede confiar en la
institucionalidad paraguaya en la
realización de un proceso electoral
limpio sin vicios teniendo en cuenta ese
episodio que terminó con el gobierno de
Lugo que para muchas personas para
muchos analistas y sectores políticos en
Paraguay fue un golpe de estado planeado
desde la oposición en ese momento con
ayuda de múltiples sectores también de
la de la institucionalidad paraguaya
usted como lo ve
Bueno
creo que la la dimensión principal o de
o de o de avance principal en estos
treinta años democracia ha sido la
dimensión electoral en la democracia
paraguaya se ha logrado constituir un
órgano rector que ha logrado
constituirse en un árbitro
que ha asegurado
competencias y elecciones que han
generado resultados sobre los cuales por
supuesto Más allá de las denuncias que
siempre hay en general son resultados
que no se han cuestionado y que por
supuesto
han dado a las autoridades electas una
legitimidad de origen muy importante en
el 2018 hay un quizás un paréntesis
de unas elecciones con un resultado muy
apretado muy muy cercano entre entre
abdo Benítez y Efraín a leer que ha
generado una serie de dudas
en los principales actores políticos en
Efraín alegre y en otros sobre esos
resultados Yo creo que el el órgano
electoral en estas elecciones que además
como mencioné tiene una nueva
conformación con los dos nuevos
ministros electos el año pasado el
Doctor César Russell y el doctor Jorge
bogarín
se plantea para el tribunal un enorme
desafío en estas elecciones de poder
continuar con esa
trayectoria digamos de un órgano que
garantiza elecciones
íntegras digamos de alguna manera o
procesos electorales íntegros ese es un
gran desafío en un contexto sumamente
delicado sumamente polarizado pero diría
yo para responder a Santiago tu pregunta
de manera directa que en materia de
institucionalidad la dimensión electoral
es quizás la dimensión que se ha
trabajado en estos más de 30 años de
democracia Katy Cuál es su opinión sobre
esto porque ya han pasado cerca de 34
años desde que finalizó la la dictadura
de Alfredo streesner qué tanto se ha
construido esta democracia y qué tan
sólida se puede considerar teniendo en
cuenta el escenario en el que estamos
teniendo en cuenta esa institucionalidad
que veníamos analizando que hay una
frecuencia que hay periodicidad en
cuanto a las elecciones y el voto
popular pero no hay alternancia que como
usted lo decía es un factor importante
para esa construcción democrática que
tanto ha cambiado la conciencia
democrática de los paraguayos tres
décadas después del fin de la dictadura
con la entrada de Nueva generaciones
justamente al proceso electoral se se
dan nuevas vibras en ese sentido Y creo
que eso también ayuda a que la
democracia se vea consolidada o trate o
esté en busca de de la
consolidación
pero coincido con lo que dice Camilo
verdad las últimas en los últimos 30
años podemos decir que las elecciones
por lo menos las generales fueron más o
menos
transparentes pero sobre todo se pudo
hacer elecciones cada cinco años que es
realmente la preocupación que teníamos
todos desde que cayó la dictadura ahora
sí
las últimas elecciones fueron muy
cuestionadas porque hablamos de una
diferencia de cerca de cien mil votos
que es nada y yo creo que esa es un
peligro que nosotros enfrentamos ahora
para el 30 de abril Porque si bien hay
una diferencia del dos por ciento en las
encuestas en las internacionales verdad
estamos hablando que una encuesta que
tiene un 2% de diferencia entre los dos
primeros candidatos con un margen de
error que Rock ronda al dos por ciento
hablamos de un empate técnico Entonces
como dice Camilo va a ser un desafío muy
grande para la justicia electoral
enfrentar esas elecciones y creo que
mucho de cómo enfrentan esas elecciones
y Cómo cuidan esas elecciones vamos a
ver impactos de diferentes tipos en el
proceso democrático en Paraguay claro y
por eso es que el América Latina está
con los ojos puestos en este país porque
es un proceso
trascendental para esa construcción
democrática y para ese desarrollo
político de este país suramericano me
quedan ya pocos minutos para finalizar
el programa como cadena internacional
tengo que hablar un poco de Paraguay en
el escenario internacional y en una
coyuntura muy particular en donde Pues
hay unos actores internacionales
destacados de Estados Unidos Rusia un
conflicto en Ucrania
un continente que da unos giros
políticos bastante particulares América
Latina y un y un grupo al cual pertenece
Paraguay que es el mercosur que está un
poco estancado y en donde Paraguay tiene
muchas diferencias también con algunos
de sus socios sobre todo por ejemplo en
el desarrollo de una relación cochina
Paraguay no tiene relación con China
tiene una relación con Taiwán y es uno
de los pocos países alrededor del mundo
que mantiene una relación cercana o
diplomática y económica con taipei Katia
para hacer la ronda la inversa escenario
internacional a dónde tiene que
proyectarse Paraguay el presidente que
llegue hacia dónde tiene que llevar a
Paraguay en la escena internacional
creo que el presidente que llegue según
cuál sea va a ver Hacia dónde va a
proyectar sus relaciones internacionales
no es lo mismo que llegue que llegue
Santiago Peña que llegue Efraín alegre
sobre todo lo que tiene que ver en el
contexto regional y en el mercosur como
vos decís que está bastante estancado no
nos olvidemos que nosotros en el 2012
recibimos una sanción y una suspensión
Pos eh juicio político golpe de estado o
como quieran llamarle a lo que a lo que
vivió Fernando Lugo entonces la idea
Creo yo que tendría que ser sobre todo
recuperar la fuerza que antes tenía
Paraguay que si bien es un país
minoritario y pequeño es
como lo puede lograr un desequilibrio
hacia alguna de las otras potencias que
integran que integran mercosur entonces
creo que esa Debería ser su Primero su
primer lugar de concentración fortalecer
el mercosur para que como bloque podamos
realmente disputar acuerdos y tratados
con mucha más fuerza que
como Islas individuales Digamos como
grupitos individuales si es que nos
fortalecemos como bloque tenemos más
fuerza de negociación con los otros
bloques con lo que nos toca negociar
Entonces yo creería que quien sea eso
debe ser su su primera tarea por
fortalecer el mercosur Y a partir de ahí
ver Hacia dónde dirige sus relaciones
sobre todo lo que te referías a las
relaciones con chinas de etcétera En
Camilo su opinión escenario
internacional
sí sin duda creo que
el Paraguay no tiene muchas chances de
de plantearse
opciones que no sean las de fortalecer
su protagonismo su participación en los
espacios regionales una participación
que tiene que ser estratégica y Creo que
lo tiene que hacer lo tiene que hacer en
el en lo que es el mercosur abdo
benítezquiso
quiso hacerlo y creo que llegó a tener
cierto éxito en cuanto al protagonismo
en en lo que fue la la objeción y la
crítica y la oposición al al al gobierno
de maduro a Venezuela en los bloques
regionales pero creo que le faltó le
faltó mayor legitimidad internacional
mayor peso digamos para poder tener un
protagonismo mayor verdad el Paraguay
tiene que fortalecer reforzar su
protagonismo su incidencia en los
espacios regionales de cooperación y de
articulación entre los estados
promoviendo por supuesto los valores
este democráticos y este
del Estado social que es lo que
justamente a lo que tenemos a lo que
nuestra democracia debería apuntar en
esta en esta etapa histórica Pues con
estas palabras del análisis de Camilo y
de Katia desde la ciudad de Asunción
ponemos punto final a este debate aquí
en France 24
panorama general de lo que está
sucediendo en Paraguay de Cara a estos
comicios electorales a estas elecciones
presidenciales que serán realizadas el
30 de abril y que por supuesto France 24
va a estar haciendo cubrimiento especial
desde Asunción y desde otros puntos del
país para llevarles a ustedes los
detalles de este proceso electoral de
suma importancia para esa construcción
democrática y ese desarrollo político de
este país suramericano Katia Camilo
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros muy bueno habernos puesto en
contexto pero sobre todo aprender de la
política paraguaya que es un país del
que tal vez hablamos poco en las cadenas
internacionales les agradezco haber
estado con nosotros y ustedes también
Muchas gracias por la sintonía En nombre
del equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado hoy en el programa que fue
producido por Laura garzón y por
Giovanni agudelo la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera y ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos los comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]